okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by larry wilmore aka
steve wood and jerry marge go large
which is on paramount plus june 17th
larry how you doing today man good i
play steve and i'm talking to steve come
on man that's dude it's it's perfect
everything comes together i love this so
speaking of steve the character you play
is it being that it's someone based on
someone in real life was it more of a
loose betrayal did you have to do like
extensive research before the part no i
don't know if there is a steve wood i'm
sure there was a character like that but
no no no to me
the only real people that mattered here
are jerry and marge you know they're the
people whose lives this is basic and all
that you know i mean
maybe you know what steve see now it
makes me want to look at that and go hmm
i wonder if there's a steve wood that's
going to watch this and go i don't think
zlatan walmart did this job
he was derelict in his duties and i mean
he at least could have called me and ask
me what i thought you know so now i felt
now i'm very sad steve thanks for
bringing that up well look i think he's
gonna see it and he's gonna be like oh
my god he nailed it and he's like nailed
it
he got me clear walmart's the only one
that truly sees me
i love that
but you know it's interesting larry
because i love all your work but also a
lot of stuff you do behind the scenes
and things so
was there a sense of freedom for you
just being an actor on this project and
not having to like worry about all the
other stuff oh steve i mean it's almost
like a dirty secret i mean i know people
are listening to this but i really
shouldn't even be saying this to be
honest with you like larry we just need
you to come here for a few weeks and
just play around with brian cranston and
benny um okay
sounds good to me
you know you don't have to do any
writing or heavy lifting and producing
that i mean it was so much fun the fact
that i could uh and not to make light of
it but you know annette benning bryan
cranston are so good you know they make
i mean they make acting in scenes with
them so easy you know so it was it was
it was kind of an honor to you know just
to be there
as kind of a
sometime actor to be in a scene with
them too you know because part of you
you kind of had the imposter syndrome go
hmm one of these things is not like the
other should i be here oh
it wasn't like that at all trust me they
were so cool and actually uh here's
something i haven't talked about yet
making a net laugh was my joy you know
just sneaking things in to kind of make
her laugh really was a lot of fun yeah
that's awesome and it's cool that i see
you as a legend so for you to still get
excited about other people like that
doesn't go away right like even though
you've worked with so many big names you
still get excited i have kids and i have
a dog i do not think of myself in that
way
you're you're mortal i do not think of
myself that way absolutely not if
anything it's the opposite you always
feel like at any time the jig's going to
be up everybody's going to see what's
really going on here that's what's
really going on yeah do you uh ever go
back and watch your performances like
will you make it like the weekend
special when it comes out with the
family go there's me or you just don't
do that
that's that's tough um
a little bit this yeah because i think
enough time has passed when i was doing
my show i couldn't watch it at all you
know
i watched it like a couple years later
go you know what my show wasn't that bad
i it was it was okay you know
yeah um
so
yeah like i look at this here's how my
brain works i go man i have way more
pandemic pounds during that movie
and i think that's all people are going
to be thinking about it's like larry get
over yourself nobody's thinking about
you just just watch the movie and enjoy
it yeah i i love that and you know and
also larry one more show was great so oh
thank you
and for larry will more loyalists like
myself
what would you say why this film to us
why someone want to give it a shot why
why this i'll tell you why steve because
we need um
inspirational stories right now we've
just gone through
and we're still going through you know
this pandemic that has really just
brought us down in so many ways let
alone all the other things that are
going on all you have to do is turn on
the tv you know there's enough there to
really have you down in so many ways we
need stories that bring us together
in ways that inspire us it's about
community it's about people being
connected and that kind of thing i'm
trying to do that more in my work steve
now too is find stories that are
inspirational that are connecting us now
because we have enough of that other
stuff so people that are fans of mine
look for not only this movie something
that you're going to feel good about
watch with the whole family by the way
but more of that in my work too
yeah i love to hear that and it's timely
and like you said you said about
yourself so everyone make sure to watch
larry crush it in jerry and marge
june 17th on fairmount plus larry thanks
for talking to me today i hope to talk
to you in the future that's my boy steve
yeah
thanks
be good larry